pour voir
tyrannie
violence
l'Europe était ravagée par la guerre la
peste et la famille
Yann j'ai besoin de votre aide
catherine est notre dernière chance de
sauver son royaume
son oncle est le roi de France vous
devez unifier l'Europe l'enlever et le
seul moyen
nous n'enlevons pas les femmes c'est le
roi qui décide il est envoyé de Dieu
oh mon dieu
j'ai besoin de VOUS vivre je n'ai pas le
choix je dois la retrouver
je sais qui est derrière tout ça c'est
soldat de la retrouveront jamais
pourquoi parce que je l'ai entraîné
demain il sera à vous vous devez la
protéger
je ferai tout ce qui est nécessaire
je réduirai en cendres chaque arbre de
la forêt
on peut pas nous laisser sans parler de
Catherine
[Musique]
qui vous choisissez de vous battre vous
mourrez peut-être
mais pour votre cause et ça c'est une
bonne note
[Musique]
les rois ont beau être choisis par Dieu
il commettent les mêmes erreurs que les
hommes
[Musique]